I'll give you an example of a really
fantastic piece of Direction I did seven
years with Chris Nolan yes and the three
Batmans Chris is not a big not Giver he
does leave you alone he's not one for
small talk you know you get there and
you're there to work and and he's very
charming and and I did a scene once in
the Batman and he came up to me and it
was probably one of two notes he ever
gave me in seven years and he said let
let's do that one more
time there's more at
stake and I went yep got it all right
let's do one more that's a fantastic
piece of Direction I don't need to know
the ins and outs of the whole universe I
just need to adjust the volume on it not
vocally right but the energy or the
dynamic of it he wants you know and I I
I always I you I use that as an example
because that is a really fantastic piece
of Direction